bonsoir bonsoir et bienvenue dans ça
vous regarde ravi de vous retrouver au
sommaire ce soir le rsa 565 euros
mensuels et un sujet qui s'invite dans
la campagne depuis qu emmanuel macron en
affaires marqueur de son programme le
président candidat veut le conditionner
à 15 à 20 heures d'activités
hebdomadaires tous les à gauche et chez
les syndicats et petits troubles aussi
au sein d'une petite partie de la
majorité alors de quoi parle-t-on
quelles sont les contreparties exigées
progrès régression sociale c'est notre
grand débat ce soir avec notre grand
témoin on va s'arrêter sur l'état de
notre démocratie alors que les
ukrainiens se bat pour un défendre la
leur la nôtre apparaît fragile et même
malade selon certains risques de forte
abstention crise de la représentation
violence contre les élus les
propositions sont nombreuses dans la
campagne pour revitaliser notre modèle
ils en parleront avec le philosophe
pierre henri tavoillot enfin enfin ce
sera le scan vous connaissez la formule
16 jours et oui seulement du premier
tour l'oeil de blacko ce soir ausculte
les chances de marine le pen de
l'emporter et puis emmanuel ducrocq de
l'opinion va décortiquer une proposition
choc qu'elle est signée sandrine
rousseau la création d'un délit de non
partage des tâches domestiques
tout un programme voilà pour mener ce
soir c'est parti là
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs merci d'être au
rendez-vous alors quelle forme quelle
forme va prendre le nouveau rsa si
emmanuel macron est réélu face au tollé
à gauche la macro ni semble avoir
quelque peu revu sa copie on va essayer
d'y voir un peu plus clair ce soir avec
vous gilles legendre bonsoir à vous
smicards député la république en marche
de paris vous nous direz précisément
quelles sont les contreparties 1 pour
bénéficier de cette allocation bonsoir
barbara gomez vous êtes porte-parole de
fabien roussel bienvenue sur ce plateau
le candidat communiste vont debout 1
contre cette proposition une arnaque
emprunté au medef dénonce t-il bonsoir
jean messia world sommes ravis de vous
accueillir sur ce plateau porte parole
d'eric zemmour vous souhaitez vous
retirez la solidarité nationale aux
étrangers non européens en leur
supprimant le rsa vous nous précisera
les choses enfin bienvenue julien
d'amont on souriait bonsoir à vous
politologues sociologues professeur à
sciences po paris spécialiste des
questions d'insertion et de lutte contre
l'exclusion je vous donne la parole dans
un instant mais d'abord on va on va
faire le point bien sûr en images sur
cette proposition et puis sur des
réactions pour le moins épidermique
qu'elle suscite maël morin avec alix
clio regarder
après un divorce un accident de la vie
comme il le dit cet ancien chef
d'entreprise s'est retrouvées sans
logement sans emploi il habite
aujourd'hui chez un ami et touchent le
rsa un revenu solidaire minimum de 560
euros en moyenne lui a droit à 497 euros
en contrepartie aucune obligation mais
emmanuel macron souhaiteraient changer
ça
il y aura dans cette réforme
l'obligation de consacrer 15 à 20 heures
par semaine pour une activité permettant
d'aller vers l'insertion professionnelle
soit formation en insertion soit
d'emploi et d'être mieux accompagnée de
dire y'a pas simplement une prestation
mais aussi un accompagnement pour
françois cloud c'est une bonne idée mais
il a quelques réticences concernant la
mise en place concrète de cette
proposition
l'année combien l'état va l'accompagner
des pompiers
c'est ça qui est important pour moi
c'est mes propose maintenant savait dès
20 heures par semaine on me dit que je
vais gagner sur les deux derniers temps
et l'état m'accompagne des temps si
c'est suffisant si c'est si ça peut me
permettre d'évoluer au lieu de rester là
mais systèmes de rsa c'est une bonne
chose mais il a peur que cette activité
ne l'empêchent de trouver un travail
ailleurs qu'en fait vous passez même le
reste du temps
c'est pas suffisant pour aller c'est
vrai
ce n'est pas suffisant ça veut dire
qu'on va vous mettre dans un système où
vous allez pas évolué un rsa revu et
corrigé une interprétation libérale
d'une mesure de gauche richard ferrand
désamorcer les critiques il ne s'agit
pas de dire c'est la location qu'étant
une subsistance contraint de travail non
ce que l'on souhaite c'est tendre la
main à ces personnes qui sont éloignés
de l'emploi ou dans l'emploi s'est
éloigné d'eux pour faire avec eux un
point voir quels accompagnements ils ont
besoin sur le plan social quête de quoi
ont-ils besoin pour retrouver une
formation bref pour revenir dans la
société pourtant à gauche c'est un tollé
unanime cette proposition est une
stigmatisation pour anne hidalgo on n'a
pas besoin d'opposer les français ce
qu'ils travailleraient ceux qui ne
travaillent pas jean luc mélenchon parle
de maltraitance sociale quand nathalie
arthaud craint une rémunération moins
élevé que le smic en revanche à droite
chez les républicains on imagine un rsa
encore plus contraignant que celui d'
emmanuel macron dans la nouvelle france
lui qui touchent le rsa donnera chaque
semaine
15 heures d'activités à la société
15 heures obligatoires tandis que dans
l'esprit des manuels macron ses
contreparties au rsa est encore un peu
flou
alors on va commencer avec vous gilles
legendre quelques chiffres pour
commencer
c'est deux millions d'allocataires en
france il faut avoir plus de 25 ans pour
percevoir le rsa
575 25 alors 175g rajouter les 10 euros
parce qu'à partir du 1er avril pour
compenser l'inflation il ya 10 euros de
plus 500 75 52 centimes exactement
863 euros 28 centimes pour un couple
sans enfant les cinq sens et quand on
est une personne seule tout ça c'est
versée par la caf via les départements
et ça coûte 12 milliards d'euros par an
à l'état quelle est la conception de la
solidarité que vous défendez avec cette
mesure en conditionnant verrai ça alors
d'abord moi je récuse totalement le
thème de contrepartie en aucun cas le
rsa va passer d'un statut d'allocations
un statut de rémunération en aucun cas
est ce que nous allons demander aux
titulaires et aux bénéficiaires du rsa
c'est de rentrer dans un projet qui leur
permettra le jour venu d'avoir une vraie
rémunération pour un vrai travail ça
veut dire que vous ne pensez pas qu'il
ya des gens qui touchent le rsa qui
préfèrent l'aide allait travailler on
jan peter nous sortons d'une longue
histoire de chômage de masse dans ce
pays dont ont été victimes des
générations entières de personnes et
évidemment les plus fragiles encore plus
que les autres les plus fragiles ce sont
soit des personnes qui sont qui ont eu
des accidents dans l'existence soit
qu'ils ne sont pas qualifiés ou armée
pour occuper des jobs va venir dans le
détail à cette question des eaux fondé
de l'accompagnement puisqu'on peut plus
dire contrepartie mais on essaie de
comprendre de quoi il s'agit mais pour
comprendre la philosophie de la mesure
parce que le revenu de subsistance
minimal c'est le rmi ça fait plus de
trente ans que ça existe il y avait une
dimension universelle aujourd'hui vous
revenez sur sa non la philosophie de 2,7
ce changement de cette réforme que nous
proposons c'est de passer d'un système
qui ne fonctionne que très mal un
système qui petit à petit nous ne
pensons pas faire la révolution du jour
lendemain fonctionnera mieux aujourd'hui
que se passe-t-il il ya 30 % des gens
qui auraient le droit au rsa qui ne le
touche pas déjà ça c'est un scandale
alors ça vous parler du non recours mais
ça va diffuser mais ça ça compte ça
compte parce que probablement sont ils
très loin si loin des dispositifs qui
n'en bénéficient pas et par ailleurs et
par ailleurs il n'ya qu'une toute petite
minorité des bénéficiaires du rsa qui au
bout de sept ans un tiers en gros qui au
bout de sept ans trouve un vrai job
c'est ans c'est long pour garder pour
nous gagner que 565 euros d'allocations
par mois c'est ça que nous avons changé
en permettant aux bénéficiaires du rsa
de se former donc c'est une opportunité
pour c'est une
que ça sera une opportunité que nous
allons concevoir sur mesure tous les
bénéficiaires du rsa ne sont pas au même
stade n'ont pas les mêmes difficultés et
à l'aimer mais on vit on était sur la
philosophie générale barbara com est-ce
que ça vous rassure c'est que c'est très
hostile vous défendez le candidat
communiste à cette mesure mais tout de
même au volant les mots ils ont
peut-être un peu évolué depuis la
présentation initiale du président
candidat mais accompagnement insertion
sur mesure ça vous rassure écoutez il ya
des dispositifs d'ailleurs à améliorer
qui existent pour que les personnes qui
sont extrêmement exclues de l'emploi et
donc d'ailleurs socialement que c'est
très compliqué pour le coude est dans
une situation de grande précarité et
d'isolement social quand on est dans
cette situation là il en a il faut les
améliorer bien entendu en revanche bien
évidemment que ça provoque un tollé un
tollé et surtout à gauche d'entendre le
mot de contrepartie d'activité pour le
reste ça parce que c'est confondre
d'abord travail est effectivement
rémunération et allocations et surtout
dans un contexte où effectivement les
grandes entreprises ont de grands
cadeaux sans contrepartie c'est plaisir
d'offrir si on donne 4,2 milliards à des
cabinets cas mckinsey par contre quand
on n'a pas beaucoup d'argent là il va
falloir faire patte blanche avec montrer
patte blanche avec en plus si je voulais
tout un grand crac sur les randos vrai
les plus meurtries sur les plans de
l'excusé compliqué bien évidemment
jamais cia eric zemmour lui fustige
l'assistanat il dit souvent quand on se
lève ce matin pour aller travailler on
n'accepte pas que le voisin vivent mieux
que soi grâce aux aides sociales
ça veut dire quoi vous allez pas à
supprimer le rsa tout de même non
certainement pas en tout cas pas dans un
premier temps puisque le rsa en fait
l'explosion des bénéficiaires du rsa
depuis le rmi dont il est le successeur
est un thermomètre si vous voulez qui
mesure le fiasco absolu des politiques
économiques poursuivi par exactement le
même système qui gouverne la france
depuis le début des années 80 non mais
on est des guillemets un pognon dengue
dans les aides sociales passées de 303
son président me de bénéfices hier quand
le rmi est né en 1988 à plus de deux
millions de bénéficiaires aujourd'hui
vous imaginez ces textes a été multiplié
par plus de 10 le nombre de
bénéficiaires mais si vous voulez on
gagne on gagne
en étant rsa qu'en travaillant ça ce
n'est pas le cas je pense qu'il ya
beaucoup aux personnes pour lesquelles
c'est le cas hélas je pense si vous
voulez que on peut on peut pas demander
575 euros par mois on peut pas demander
oui mais auxquels s'ajoutent d'autres
dispositifs la plupart du temps c'est
pas une troisième sociale exactement
c'est pour ça qu eric zemmour
globalement il entend si vous voulez
réserver tous les dispositifs qui relève
de la solidarité nationale à commencer
par le rsa aux seuls citoyens français
et européens parce que la solidarité
derrière il ya le mot nationale il faut
pas l'oublier ce n'est que là c'est pas
une solidarité mondiale on peut pas sans
arrêt demander des efforts aux français
pour financer un modèle de celle de
solidarité qui serait devenue mondiale
mais je terminerai en disant quelque
chose encore plus important que cela
c'est que en fait en réalité au mais les
bénéficiaires du rsa avec la mesure de
monsieur macron dans une seringue c'est
à dire qu'on les oblige finalement à
trouver du travail mais le problème
c'est que le contexte et l'environnement
économique est très malthusien en
travail alors je sais que vous allez me
sortir les éternels cinq cent mille
emplois qu'ils sont pas pourvus mais ça
ça relève du chômage frictionnel
c'est le chômage c'est le chômage
frictionnel qui avait existé moi je
crois que pour sortir de l'assistanat il
faut d'abord une politique économique
qui fasse de l'emploi une priorité
absolue et qui créent des emplois
nous avons un point d'arrivée c'est le
seul je m'empresse de le dire vous vous
dit le seul herreshoff que vous ayez
d'ailleurs vous êtes là nous sommes en
train de faire non mais attendez nous
avons réduit de trois points le taux de
chômage c'est faux et le président dans
ses choix ses engagements je suis à la
question véritable a dévié sur un débat
sur l'emploi c'est que vous adoriez
c'est bien je suis en mai on va je
savais que vous adorez vrai pas buyin et
les français avec ses fans l'ont fait
hier pas dont il n'y a pas de baisse de
l'enduro du taux de chômage en france à
bord ont toutes toutes catégories
confondues on a toutes catégories
confondues c'est le même et c'est même
peut-être accrue depuis 2017 mais
monsieur le député a raison c'est à dire
qu'on peut pas parler de la
problématique du rsa et de son coût si
on parle pas de l'environnement
macroéconomique dans celle des gens
évoluent question tout ça en temps si tu
aimerais le diagnostic de julien d'amour
qui va nous dire si ça marcherait ou pas
cette cette mesure pourquoi vous
pourquoi vous attaquez pas aux usa en
tant qu' en tant que allocations et vous
devez seulement les étrangers si vous
dites vous même que le système ne marche
pas c'est la location c'est l'aide en
elle même qu'il faudrait réformer quand
vous avez vous enlevez que les étrangers
ça ne va pas résoudre le problème quand
même quand on est content on a quand
même doute de vous l'avez dit vous-même
12 milliards nous nous estimons à 15
milliards c'est une question d une amie
c'est une assertion les deux c'est à
dire que effectivement ça peut pas se
leurrer limiter à une mesure comptable
je viens de l'expliquer c'est là que par
ailleurs il faut une politique macro
économiques volontaristes pour créer des
fils y est de recréer des filières
industrielles relocaliser l'emploi en
france ray une ré industrialiser la
france qui permettra justement de vider
cette poche d'assistanat qui est lié un
chômage de masse sur une très longue
durée alors julien d'amont puis on va
essayer de ne voir plus clair sur cet
accompagnement dans le détail petit
bilan ça fait quoi tu 40 ans le rmi rsa
là où ça fait à peu près un tiers de
siècle est-ce que ça a marché dans le
rmi il y avait à la fois le revenu et la
dimension insertion nom des gens de la
misère et réinsérer voilà je vous fais
un bilan alors le rmi a échoué parce que
le i du rmi n'a pas fonctionné le
système d'insertion qui avait été mis en
place n'a pas fonctionné le rsa ne
fonctionne pas parce que son a ne
fonctionne pas actuellement exactement
c'est à peu près la même chose le rémy
est le héros aujourd'hui même si
techniquement ont été enlevés toutes les
barrières possible à la reprise d'un
emploi formel c'est à dire que
aujourd'hui sur le papier il est tout à
fait
gagnant pour tout allocataire du rsa de
retrouver un emploi ont glissé l'idée
qu'en gros il ya des profiteurs mais
préfère la location et d'autres aides
plutôt que travailler mais c'est faux ça
dépend de ce qu'on appelle travail et
veulent travailler formelle et vous avez
le travail informel vous avez des gens
qui sont contraints d'exercer des
activités au noir pour compléter ce
revenu qui est si faible donc au regard
du travail formel celui que peut
proposer tout employeur ou que peu
sachez a cherché à fournir pôle emploi
tout entier tout allocataire du rsa a
intérêt à retravailler modulo ses frais
de déplacement modulo aussi ses frais de
garde d'enfants maintenant il est dans
une certaine mesure inciter à exercer
des activités qui sont informelles alors
ça c'est un sujet qui d'ailleurs n'est
assez rarement qui est assez rarement
abordés et qui était un des sujets
essentiels du dossier sur les
propositions qui sont faites aujourd'hui
je dirais que ça revient à l'essence
même du projet de revenu minimum
d'insertion h 15 à 20 heures
le point le plus important du rmi
s'était pas seulement le revenu il faut
toujours aller seul à l'esprit que le
rsa aujourd'hui élevé rémy autrefois
c'est un instrument à double face vous
avez un revenu minimum et vous avez ce
qu'aujourd'hui on baptise un
accompagnement scopar avant on baptisait
de l'insertion et monsieur messier a
raison de citer le chiffre de 300 mille
personnes lorsque l'on fait en 1988 les
projections pour dire combien il y
aurait d'allocataires du rmi on disait
ça ne dépassera jamais 300 mille
aujourd'hui avec 2 millions le système
est aujourd'hui dépassée par l'ampleur
des personnes à accompagner je pense que
dans les propositions qui sont faites
l'idée de mettre en avant d'abord la
question de l'accompagnement et ensuite
la question de la rémunération qui n'est
pas une rémunération d'un salaire de la
location c'est une révolution si d'abord
on traite de façon individualisé par des
conseillers dédiés les problèmes des
gens plutôt que de seulement verser la
prestation comme c'est le cas
aujourd'hui qui est le signe de l'échec
du système on peut véritablement aider
le monsieur qu'on a vu dans le petit
reportage et les deux millions de
personnes qui sont aujourd'hui avocat
conseiller d'état et ça veut dire de
mission locale on va essayer de
comprendre je voudrais quand même vous
sollicitez dans votre camp j'ai le
gendre parce que ça fait en gros une
grosse semaine que cette annonce a été
faite par emmanuel macron et les mots on
le voit bien ils ont un peu évolué au
sein de votre famille politique et où
quelques doutes pour ne pas dire
quelques critiques écoutez
effectivement ça a provoqué un certain
nombre d'interrogations à certains
troubles des explications qu'on a eu la
ministre du travail qui ont vraiment
fini par nous convaincre
c'est une mesure qui fait aujourd'hui
débat au sein même de la majorité est ok
avec ça vous pas moi je crois du champ
vous savez notamment
jean non sans que voilà à l'est d'el
gauche la jambe gauche j'approuve cette
expression là mais aussi au sein de la
macro ni s'interroge est-ce que encore
une fois il n'y a pas de volonté de
punir une campement en aucun cas une
campagne électorale c'est ça c'est un
candidat ce sont des candidats qui
acceptent de prendre des risques en
mettant dans le débat des mesures qu'il
pense nécessaire pour le pays alors
celle-ci en est une il y en a d'autres y
en aura d'autres y en a d'autres qui
viennent d'autres candidats personne n'a
le monopole dans ce domaine mais je
pense que c'est important qu'on
s'adresse aux français en leur disant
exactement ce qu'on veut faire pour a
créé la lettre et là c'est un chant on
est plus sur 15 à 20 heures de travail
c'est pas une personne au rsa qui doit
aller par exemple est caissier dans un
supermarché c'est pas ça parce que les
modes ce n'est pas un job n est pas se
former mais yahia mukawa c'est
travailler alors les mots les modérés
dans des parcours d'insertion c'est
travail paris dément non jean messia
vous pouvez pas dire ça la voie de
garage tuque
la loi diarra chelsea se passe
aujourd'hui pour une trop grande partie
des bénéficiaires du rsa et vous savez
trés sont tellement loin de l'emploi
qu'il touche une allocation qui est
modeste qui est indispensable mais qui
est modeste et qui ne voient aucune
perspective un jour de toucher un
salaire monsieur lemay savoir ce député
est ce que vous savez à la voix de cette
voie de garage qu'il faut que nous
mettions fait ce que vous savez que leur
que le le rsa aujourd'hui dans de
nombreux quartiers c'est juste un
complément de revenu en fait parce que
vous avez une fraude massive on l'a bien
que dans certains dans certaines zones
où le rsa ce super heroes avec le
travail au noir avec le fruit de
certains travaux c'est pour ça que nous
proposons la mise en place on a le
brigade nationale anti fraude de
répondre à madame angoissée pour lutter
contre cela je veux dans la parole
jamais c'est l'accompagnement sais quoi
parce que elisabeth bornel prononce des
mots comme immersion en entreprise
formation prendre contact avec le monde
professionnel avec des ateliers pour
faire des bilans de compétences
apprendre à faire un cv c'est toute une
palette et c'est quelque chose je le
redis d' je le disais tout à l'heure en
introduction qui fondamental le concept
c'est du sur mesure et la vraie
révolution je vais vous parler très
franchement ça n'est pas tant qu'on
change un tout petit peu la philosophie
du dispositif
mais c'est qu'on soit capable et ça
c'est un défi que nous allons devoir
relever de rendre ce service sur mesure
ça va coûter précisément le candidat la
ministre actuelle du travail ont donné
des indications dans ce sens ça suppose
une assez grande réorganisation
pose une grande réorganisation crds et
man leur apprend les départements il ya
des musiques sur locale voilà les
missions locales le pôle emploi cie va
s'appeler sans ce travail d'ici ni
personnes qui vont être disponibles mais
même si ça coûtait un peu plus cher moi
je préfère qu'on dépense même un tout
petit peu plus de l'argent non et qu'on
réorganise les choses avec des résultats
à l'arrivée ayez un deuxième point que
je voudrais sur lequel voudrait insister
qu'on a évoqué le disait c'était le seul
peut-être points d'accord nous avions
avec monsieur messier il ya un
changement radical qui est en train de
s'opérer dans ce pays depuis des années
nous avons souffert d'un chômage de
masse toujours au dessus de bliss raison
de 6 11%
il est évident que l'image de masse il
était extraordinairement difficile de
rendre efficace des dispositifs comme
celui du rsa tel qu'il avait été conçu à
l'origine aujourd'hui nous nous mettons
en position d'avoir le plein emploi à la
fin du quinquennat
qu'est ce que c'est là dit ça on dit
seck le plein en ont jamais mais sinon
si jamais c'est comme ces plaintes mais
ses jambes et mesure qui aura pris
l'avion rapide aux sdf à la fin du
quinquennat on voit le résultat un plein
emploi ne soyez pas gré silence c'est
vrai le plein emploi c'est autour de
carhaix pour cent il est évident que
s'il n'ya plus que 4% de chômeurs il est
beaucoup plus facile d'aller bien vers
l'emploi les personnes qui aujourd'hui
en centre et son épouse d' écouter
barbara gomes qui s'est un peu moins
j'ai exprimé que vous est-ce que s
confond ça vous semble plus acceptable
expliqué comme ça avec et des embauches
des embauches des emplois publics ça
veut dire un danger pour les mesures
locales depuis le départ c'est qu'il
faut embaucher on peut pas faire comme
ça passe et de l'emploi c'est à dire ce
travail qui donne accès à un statut avec
des droits particuliers du travail à la
protection sociale au chômage et c'est à
une activité non protégés non rémunéré
on gagne on travaille pour même pas
avant le smic donc bien entendu qui dit
heureux qu'on bascule d'un d'une
activité a finalement des aides à la
formation individuelle vous êtes plutôt
en phase un peu on ne peut qu'aller vers
le sens va du fait et c'est ce qu'on
disait de culte alors un de renforcer
les formations de donner accès aux
toutes les personnes à un travail il
faut absolument aider davantage
effectivement les missions locales mais
aussi tous les dispositifs d'insertion
dans l'emploi c'est évident mais
attention et peut-être une dernière
chose là dessus c'est important de dire
emploi est d'ailleurs le basculement de
pôle emploi france travaille à titre
personnel et je pense que c'est partagé
par de nombreuses personnes à gauche et
m'interpelle pourquoi parce que je vous
le disais tout à l'heure l'emploi c'est
le travail mais qui donne accès à un
statut protecteur et quand on voit
effectivement des glissements je pense à
l'ubs et risation du travail on a des
gens qui travaillent énormément sans
statut sans rémunération dans des
conditions de travail indignes et qu'à
côté effectivement on peut avoir des
sorties sur le rsa où on nous dit on à
des allocataires qui maintenant vont
devoir en plus avoir des activités pour
réussir à justifier l'aumône bah ça
n'est pas possible donc il faut en tout
cas on voit on voit que vous n'êtes pas
si éloigné que ça en revanche avec vous
jean bessière et xénon est très clair
c'est c'est pas d'accompagnement pour le
rsa est ce que la proposition de valérie
pécresse parce qu'elle est proche est un
peu différente c'est de demander aux
allocataires
des travaux d'intérêts généraux alors là
c'est gratuit pour les collectivités
locales une forme de deux contributions
on l'entendait dans le sujet la société
ça ne veut rien dire je crois si vous
voulez que le simple fait de rémunérer
fin de considérer que le rsa n'est plus
une allocation de solidarité mais ça
devient en quelque sorte un salaire qui
est bien moindre que le smic vous
transformer en fait les bénéficiaires du
rsa en armée de réserve concept cher aux
communistes en enchères si vous voulez à
travail à corvéable et malléable à merci
et nous refusons catégoriquement de
rentrer dans cette logique
la deuxième chose si vous voulez c'est
que le comment dirais-je le le rsa est
un est un mécanisme dont on doit sortir
par le haut pas par le bas c'est à dire
pas un emploi parce qu'en fait le rsa
dans les loges dans la logique dans
l'orthodoxie progressiste le le rsa est
une est une trappe à inactivité en fait
ils sortent de de cataplasme qu'on
applique pour tacler jean explose parce
que le système mis en place depuis 40
ans le supprimer mais sait pas s'ils
voulaient eux ils sont spécialistes pour
faire du maquillage c'est à dire on va
changer le nom de pôle emploi en france
travaillent on va faire des réformes de
réorganisation du service on va
personnaliser mais le problème
ça me fait penser à un bon vous dites
vous même que le rsa ne fonctionne pas
bien ça mais à bien des égards vous avez
raison pourquoi devrait-on laisser
intact pourquoi ne faut-il pas changé
c'est pourquoi ne faut-il pas de
problème vous savez votre politique et
me rappelle un proverbe égyptiens qu'ils
n'ont rien pu faire contre le cheval ils
se sont excités sur la selle le cheval
étant l'économie et à la capacité de
l'économie a créé du temps on a des dons
crise était fixé à le changement vers la
relégation l'emploi le redis seule la
vivace et pau points à l'actif de notre
bilan c'est le fait qu'on ait remis
l'ept l'économie en marche je viens dame
tout le monde le dit le les économistes
français les économistes internationaux
et les investisseurs
mais ce bilan des papillons du à lens
c'est un débat julien damon les duels
pourtant sur le proverbe égyptien je
pense quand même que sur la scène il est
très important que le cheval soit bien
seul et et que à cette matière le rsa le
rsa soit là celle d'une économie qui
fonctionne mieux tant mieux le truc
c'est que depuis 30 ans revient ce sujet
qui en gros on va mettre un peu les
pauvres au boulot évoqué les
propositions du type mal formulé
peut-être alarm explicitement formulée
du côté des républicains qui consiste à
dire allez hop presque un mi temps par
semaine donc un mi temps par mois un mi
temps par année je vais mettre au
travail 2 millions de personnes ont fait
un calcul très simple règle de trois ça
fait un million d'emplois qu'il faudrait
trouver plus des quelques centaines de
milliers de personnes qui vont les
encadrer
c'est totalement inenvisageable ce qui
est en revanche à mon avis parfaitement
judicieux c'est de dire nous recomposons
ce qu'on appelle aujourd'hui
l'accompagnement c'est à dire le conseil
emploi de pôle emploi les activités des
missions locales qui sont
essentiellement pour les jeunes donc
très peu conscient je vais vous voyez
bien que en fait les gens n'ont
absolument pas compris parce que entre
ce qu'est
ce que ça devienne aujourd'hui c'est
très très 10 le sujet le plus important
avant la vie aujourd'hui c'est pas de
recomposer le rsa tel qu'il est en tant
que prestations pendant cinq ans on a
travaillé dans en chambre et c'est
extraordinaire on a fait des projets
pour ce qu'il a été baptisé un revenu
universel d'activité fusionnant quelques
prestations non n'a pas ouvert le champ
de l'accompagnement et la rend justement
vous vous êtes invités aussi
revenu d'engagement jeune il était le
nom l'idée fait rage voilà l'idée c'est
un peu généralisés puisqu'on fait l'idée
c'était déjà pour tout l'est pour tous
les jeunes qui n'avaient pas ni d'études
ni deux ni nos diplômes qui était un peu
en dehors de système on les
accompagnaient et là c'était un million
de personnes n'en rajouterai 2 millions
annoncés parmi eux personne ne recyclent
aujourd'hui vous avez cent mille
personnes qui sont concernées l'objectif
qu'il s'était longuement gags et
l'elysée auquel il est l'idole il décide
d'abord de les accompagner les sortir de
leur divinité biens-fonds
personnellement je l'enverrai ma
question est ce que c'est faisable
est-ce que vous avez les moyens
endomètre dans les missions locales des
personnes souvent derrière chaque
allocateur pour les accompagner sur
mesure un problème de doctrine sur la
pauvreté c'est que plus vous êtes en
difficulté plus à des gens qui sont
censés s'occuper de vous donc un des
grands sujets c'est comment rationaliser
cela vous avez les missions locales d'un
côté pôle emploi de l'autre la sphère
associative dans sa diversité qui
exercent pour le compte des pouvoirs
publics les mêmes fonctions le
département qui va faire ça en est
également les centres communaux d'action
sociale qui sont les services d'action
perd ses moyens je pense que d'abord
réfléchir à moyens constants est
vraiment se donner un objectif qui est
que chaque allocataire du rsa est un
projet personnalisé et une personne qui
soit responsable de son dossier et qui
soit cette personne elle même noté sur
ses activités d'accompagnement et bien
c'est ça le projet utile pour autant se
remettre
c'est ça alors on a parlé tout à l'heure
du sur mesure quant au type de formation
de mécanismes d'insertion qu'il faudrait
proposer pour les adapter exactement aux
besoins on va aussi faire du sur mesure
en fonction de la situation objective
des bénéficiaires des bénéficiaires du
rsa ils sont certains dans des
situations très très différentes il ya
peut-être et c'est vrai un certain
nombre de bénéficiaires du rsa pour
lequel ce travail d'insertion sera
particulièrement difficile mais c'est si
ces familles monoparentales
on l'a dit sa hâte je crois que ça a été
dit par gabriela talent je crois pas
plus tard que ce matin le fait qu'il
faudrait trouver des solutions
spécifiques pour les mamans qui élèvent
leurs enfants seuls et pour qui il est
difficile de quitter le foyer quand on
n'a évidemment pas les moyens de payer
par là et puis il ya les accidents il ya
des personnes malades et des personnes
non ils ne sont pas exclues tout le
monde ira droit et vous savez dès lors
que ce n'est pas une contrainte que nous
créons mais un droit c'est un droit
supplémentaire légal et nous attachons
que nous assez drôle parce que pour que
cela n'ait pas dit depuis le début c'est
un ballon d'essai
journée remet mémoire vous avez vu quand
combien de temps le candidat au milieu
d'eux un nombre extrêmement important de
mesures pendant sa conférence de presse
à aborder ce point c'est normal que
derrière ces soutiens et nous sommes
nombreux à le faire explique détails et
puis et puis et puis qu'on entende aussi
comprendre jusqu'où vous êtes voilà
précis sur cette mesure des missions
locales l'accompagnement je crois que
c'est clair vous pouvez cumuler donc si
vous acceptez une formation avec un
autre venu le rsa plus aussi même vous
trouver un petit job ça c'est pas exclu
crois qu'il est après il a été dit fasse
de façon très claire que si quelqu'un
retrouvait un vrai emploi une vraie
activité justifiant l'attrait salaires
évidemment les choses s'adapterait c'est
le but le but encore une fois c'est que
à terme que ne fixe évidemment aucun
terme y ait le moins de gens possible
qui bénéficient du rsa et gagnent et
kata et qu'à la place il est un salaire
et le salaire aujourd'hui il est régi
par une loi qui s'appelle le smic mais
donc le smic reviendrait en cas ce mic
horaires en cas de reprise d'activité
même partielle moi j'ai qu'il ya quelque
chose que j'ai du mal à comprendre c'est
qu'avant de vous lancer dans une grande
réorganisation qui probablement
indispensable du rsa de ses
bénéficiaires des mesures
d'accompagnement d'insertion qui sont
indispensables pourquoi ne commencez
vous pas pas remettre à plat qui profite
du ces du rsa est qui et qui n'en
profite pas je dirai pas ce que si quand
vous avez un nombre quand même assez
considérable d'étrangers ne l'européen
qui bénéficie vous pouvez pas on peut
pas s'ils voulaient entendre tous les
membres du gouvernement venir jouer les
gueules dans plaignent sur les sur les
plateaux en nous expliquant que le
dispositif coûte très cher etc
l'esc enseignants madame écho à celle où
le sujet est gênant mais
il faut il faut l'aborder je pense qu'il
faut quand quand on a un dispositif qui
coûte 12 à 15 milliards d'euros par an
la première des choses quand même c'est
quand même une somme considérable qui
représente des budgets ministériels
d'accord mais il faut mettre le
dispositif a pas à plat et réduire déjà
le nombre d'usagers si je puis dire ou
de bénéficiaires voilà quatre ans j'ai
nous connaissons votre mandat robert
nous connaissons l'obsession de la tribu
zemmour qui est de tourner celle de la
france ce week-end oui toujours tout
vouloir relié au cas la durance les
interventions à la france vous en
entraînerait certainement pas sur ce
sujet c'est ça n'est pas le sujet c'est
possible si
chacun un petit mot pour conclure julien
daneault puis je vous donnerai le mot de
la fin ma part j'en prends deux sur les
étrangers sur le rsa en général sur les
étrangers les étrangers extra
communautaires quand le rmi a été créé
il fallait deux ans de présence en
situation régulière sur le territoire
avant de pouvoir bénéficier du rmi
aujourd'hui avec le rsa c'est cinq ans
il n'empêche que les questions sur le
territoire on citera de séjour pour les
espoirs extra communautaires pour les
européens c'est différent meyer
marmaille sur le rsa c'est qu'on a
toujours la pression notamment sur les
plateaux de télé sauf que lorsqu'il y a
une personne qui est concernée qui prend
la parole que c'est un petit truc
marginal et c'est le hassania toujours
beaucoup de chiffres pour donner une
seule idée le nombre de personnes que
jolie sont bénéficiaires c'est à dire
allocataires directement ou conjoints ou
enfants tout ceci fait à peu près 5% de
la population française aujourd'hui si
on regarde depuis un tiers de siècle
depuis que ça a été créée vais pas de
15% de la population française qui a été
concerné donc c'est pas du tout un sujet
second c'est un sujet absolument
essentiel et qui peut commander des
révolutions dans l'organisation c'est
moins sexy que les grands sujets de
bagarres immigration emploi la
réorganisation de l'accompagnement la
selle sur le cheval c'est très important
barbara gomez pour conclure j'ai
l'impression que vous êtes assez
convaincus par la philosophie de cet
accompagnement alors je suis convaincu
par le fait qu'il faut effectivement
revoir un petit peu comment on
accompagne ces personnes qui encore une
fois quand on est au rsa on n'est pas
dans une situation des ans on ne sait
vraiment quoi dire là bien compliqué et
aujourd'hui on a des situations plein de
finnair en tension ou parler des
départements tout à l'heure on sait
qu'on a extrêmement besoin d'avoir des
fonctionnaires territoriaux par exemple
deux à l'aide sociale à l'enfance des
assistants sociaux verte est vital
ratera forcément les moyens si on
romaine et sa bande un accompagnement
dans les justes on a on a une politique
publique extrêmement fortes dans les
hôpitaux et dans tous les endroits déjà
où on a la main ne serait-ce que l'état
pour pouvoir donner des formes action
des personnes qui ne demandent que ça
comme vous aviez vu le monsieur qui
témoignait tout à l'heure les gens
veulent travailler alors si on leur
donne du vrai travail avec un vrai
emploi avec un smic à 1200 euros comme
le propose le pr 1500 euros quand même
des impôts celles parmi 900 euros voilà
comme le smic à 1500 euros pour le bruit
de fadas de fabien roussel là
effectivement on est dans de l'emploi
digne et mc cann et ça qu'on sort qu'on
sorte du mauvais cheval merci beaucoup
merci c'était beaucoup plus clair comme
ça merci d'avoir accepté de débattre de
ces sujets on va accueillir à présent un
philosophe pour évoquer l'état de notre
démocratie son ouvrage comment gouverner
un peuple le roi chez odile jacob est
devenu une référence et avec lui on va
parler de notre système institutionnel
que beaucoup décrivent à bout de souffle
à l'heure où l'abstention menace ou
certains posent même la question de la
légitimité d'une élection sans débat ni
confrontation n'a beaucoup de questions
à poser à pierre-henri tavoillot comme
les skis ce sujet de marc au poignet
regarde si on vous invite pierre henri
tavoillot ces pourparlers démocratie
notre modèle démocratique libéral serait
malade à bout de souffle qu'en pensez
vous en pleine campagne présidentielle
les candidats eux rivalisent de
propositions
oui je crois que la france a besoin de
plus de démocratie plus de démocratie ça
veut dire la proportionnelle ça veut
dire des référendum sur des grands
sujets 16 ans nous le ferons en france
voici venu le
travail
pendant des mois nous allons mener
une espèce de nouveaux grands débats
permanents pour agir pierre henri
tavoillot vous êtes philosophe maître de
conférences à l'université paris
sorbonne mais aussi président du collège
de philosophie dans vos livres vous vous
intéressez à l'art politiques entendent
démocratie et votre parole est à rebours
de la tendance du moment car pour vous
le vrai grand mystère de la démocratie
c'est qu'elle fonctionne je conçois la
démocratie il faut presque raisonner à
l'envers c'est quand on réfléchit à ce
qu'elle est par essence c'est un régime
qui est totalement absurde elle nous
promet la liberté l'égalité la
fraternité vert n'est pas donc déception
elle nous promet un régime où nous nous
donnons à nous mêmes nos lois et nous
allons y obéir franchement c'est
délirant et troisièmement sa définition
la plus grandiose celle de lincoln le
gouvernement du peuple par le peuple
pour le peuple on sait pas ce que c'est
qu'un gouvernement et on ne sait pas qui
est le peuple ce peuple que vous
qualifiez deux peuples roissy difficile
à gouverner dans un espace public où de
plus en plus de citoyens décident de
s'abstenir ou certains clament leur
colère dans les rues réclame plus de
référendum plus de convention citoyenne
aussi vous vous êtes plutôt un fervent
défenseur de notre démocratie
représentative
des souvent que notre démocratie souffre
d'une crise de la représentation je
pense pas que ce soit le problème parce
que jamais nous autres avons été aussi
bien représenté les élus sont en quête
de savoir ce qu'on pense si on a froid
si on a chaud si on éternue le vrai
problème c'est l'impuissance publique un
puissance publique et pourtant pierre
henri tavoillot vous soulignez la
résistance de notre régime face aux
crises alors monsieur le philosophe
à l'heure où les ukrainiens se bat pour
défendre leur démocratie à l'heure où 34
% des jeunes adhèrent réalité que
l'armée puisse diriger le pays d'après
une enquête ifop éclairez nous une seule
et grande question ce soir est ce qu'on
attend pas trop de la démocratie à vous
la parole
bonsoir clair en richesse loyaux merci
d'être là ce soir bien on va commencer
par cette grande question est ce qu'on
n'est pas trop exigeant avec le moins
pire des systèmes politiques pour
paraphraser churchill est ce qu'on n'est
pas trop demandeur à une démocratie qui
est déjà là et dont il faut déjà se
féliciter c'est un peu le paradoxe c'est
plus la démocratie réussi plus on en
veut encore et donc plus ça marche mois
on constate que ça marche pas assez et
donc c'est ça le problème structurel et
c'est vrai qu'il faut l'aborder si je
puis dire on adultes c'est à dire
l'adulte sait qui c'est quelqu'un qui
sait que voilà il n'est pas tout
puissant mais il peut faire quand même
un certain nombre de choses et donc il
faut renoncer à ce désir un peu
adolescents de la toute puissance pour
essayer de se focaliser sur le possible
raymond aron disait il ya l'idéal il ya
le réel et entre les deux il possible
c'est ça la démocratie le réel
aujourd'hui c'est quand même une
démocratie qui va pas très bien en
france vous n'êtes pas d'accord avec ce
diagnostic malade on entend dire souvent
alors oui il faut pas non plus trop
sombrer dans la séduction de la
crépusculaire où la décadence notons
quelques points positifs par exemple
notre démocratie représentative est
quand même très participative il ya 600
mille élus en france tiers six cent
mille personnes à peu près qui décide de
consacrer leur vie pas simplement un
coup de zapping issilame est consacré
leur vie à la démocratie locale je crois
que c'est un record du monde ça veut
dire qu'un citoyen sur sont grosso modo
et est un élu et un élu c'est sa vie
c'est pas quelque chose de ponctuel donc
ça c'est un signe de vitalité
évidemment il abstention par ailleurs
mais oui je pense qu'il faut être
attentif et nous dit on est finalement
bien représentés mais quand vous voyez
au fond cette demande du citoyen d'être
associé davantage à la décision publique
quand vous voyez la violence aussi
contre les élus quand on comprend bien
que peut-être notre système
institutionnel la vème république
l'inversion du calendrier avec la
présidentielle les statiques que le
parlement a bien du mal à montrer qu'il
a une marge de manoeuvre est ce qu'on
n'est pas quand même dans un problème de
représentation alors je pense que c'est
pas le problème le plus profond si vous
la clé de l'aneld la question de la
démocratie représentative
c'est vraiment l'idée de savoir pourquoi
on vote alors qu'on voit tous les jours
qu'il ya des moyens plus efficaces
de manifester de faire changer les
choses il suffit de faire une petite
manie l'efficacité des voilà donc donc
voté paraît assez peu efficace il vit
par ailleurs on constate que les élus
quels que soient leur bonne volonté et
bien peuvent pas grand chose en vérité
sont relativement impuissants parce que
nous avons des murs à et d'impossibilité
et donc le citoyen avec beaucoup de
l'impuissance oui je pense que cela est
dû vous la voyez à tous les étages oui
je la vois toi vous voyez un maire
aujourd'hui il est assez ils risquent
beaucoup il peut peut si je puis dire et
donc c'est cette situation un peu
étonnante contre laquelle il faut lutter
si nous sommes dans un régime de
démocratie libérale et s'est constitué
de deux jambes il ya le des massilia le
kratos le peuple et le pouvoir
fondamentalement les libéraux se méfiait
du pouvoir il disait bon il faut libérer
la société parce que le pouvoir c'est
toujours de l'abus de pouvoir
aujourd'hui on est peut-être dans une
situation un tout petit peu différent il
faut bien veiller au curseur on a
peut-être trop de contre-pouvoir
peut-être pause possiblement des abus de
contre-pouvoir qui empêche le poids or
s'il ya plus pour en démocratie il ya
plus de démocratie alors c'est ça le
vrai nous du problème pouvoirs et
contre-pouvoirs sur l'abstention on en
parlait à l'instant les enquêtes
d'opinion relève un risque de forte
abstention pour ne pas dire massive pour
une élection maîtresse qui est
d'ordinaire passionne les français
comment vous l'expliquez est ce que
c'est un vrai signe d'inquiétude pour
vous alors il ya plusieurs facteurs
d'explication qu'il faut essayer de
série est d'abord il ya le fait
qu'effectivement on est dans une
campagne qui est assez particulière non
campagne disent beaucoup oui moi je
dirais pas non campagne parce que les
programmes sont sur la table il ya d un
débat d'idées simplement des anciens un
contexte où on a le souvenir d'une
précédente campagne qui était comme une
série netflix jeudi il y avait des
péripéties avec une intensité dramatique
et donc on se dit il se passe rien
aujourd'hui alors qu'en vérité une vraie
campagne c'est ce qui se passe et des
programmes sur la table des débats
d'idées s'il n'y a pas de d'effets de
manche mais c'est ça ça c'est le premier
point deuxième point il ya un candidat
un président candidat qui a de bonnes
chances de l'emporter et donc du coup le
suspense ultime de cette compétence sont
assez importants c'est moi et surtout il
ya un candidat il ya une campagne qui se
déroule troisièmement dans une situation
de crise or les situations de crise on
général encline aux légitimisme satire
11 10 il ya beaucoup de risques il y
aura au moins quelqu'un qui est aux
manettes qui sait à peu près comment
comment gérer les crises il l'a montré
par le passé donc c'est peut-être pas le
moment de changer et donc ces trois
éléments un pas de péripéties 2 1
pas de voile a pas de pas d'enjeu
particulier pas de suspense particuliers
et 3 une situation de crise font que
nous pouvons avoir le sentiment d'une
absence de campagne mais je rappelle un
point très important dans toutes les
élections les gens sont déçus par la
campagne électorale vous pourrez
remonter aussi loin est un peu à
contre-courant sur tout ce qui sera
longue dans les médias aujourd'hui non
campagne risque des légitimités vous
avez vu cette charge de gérard larcher
dans le figaro si emmanuel macron ne
participe à un débat avec ses opposants
la question de sa légitimité sera posée
s'il est réélu c'est un argument de
bonne guerre de la part des opposants
mais ses patins ce n'est pas un argument
qu'il était judicieux c'était pas un
argument qui porte parce que de toute
façon il ya des règles du jeu et encore
une fois rien ne dit que la campagne
doit se dérouler d'une certaine manière
la campagne doit être ouverte et
équitable voilà c'est ça le principe
après sur les modalités chacun fait
comme il veut alors il ya beaucoup de
propositions dans cette campagne pour
revitaliser
refaire fonctionner notre démocratie
marine le pen qui propose évidemment là
la proportionnelle tout comme d'ailleurs
une dose de proportionnelle pour le
candidat président emmanuel macron quand
on a 30 % des voix en 2007 au 2e tour
est ce que c'est normal d'avoir
seulement six députés faut changer ça
non c'est pas normal du tout le débat
sur la professionnelle objectivement
compliqué cirque
moi je n'ai pas de philosophie
particulière là dessus si je puis dire à
ceci près qu je trouve qu'il ya un
défaut dans la proportionnelle c'est que
ça éloigne encore l'élu de l'électeur
c'est à dire qu'on a et ça disons ça
donne au parti le rôle de désigner qui
sera élu donc un déficit démocratique
dans la proportionnelle qui menait
alors même qu'on dit aujourd'hui les
élus sont éloignés des électeurs ce qui
n'est à mon sens ce n'est pas vrai mais
ça ajouterait cet éloignement mais en
vérité aussi c'est pour ça que je suis
très très embarrassé je trouve
qu'effectivement le fait que le
rassemblement national qui sera
peut-être au deuxième tour et une
représentation aussi faible est juste
une anomalie énorme colossal donc là
c'est un problème parle aussi de moyens
de résoudre peut-être la question de
l'abstention pour redonner de l'enjeu de
la comptabilisation du vote blanc c'est
vraiment une demande des français quand
on les interroge ses massifs a
comptabilisé le vote blanc parmi des
suffrages exprimés pourquoi pas couplées
cette mesure avec une forme de vote
obligatoire qu'est ce que vous en pensez
là aussi je suis très très conservateur
je suis totalement contre les deux
blancs vote obligatoire parce que alors
vote obligatoire dans les mocratie
athénienne on n'avait pas le droit on
est obligé de voter plus ou moins
d'ailleurs et on n'avait pas le droit de
vote blanc sinon c'était l'exil voyez
donc c'était dur les démocratie
athénienne le vote obligatoire je pense
qu'on est dans une démocratie libérale
on a le droit de décider de ne pas jouer
voilà simplement si on ne joue pas il
faut pas demander à la reconnaissance du
vote blanc je trouve que voter c'est une
situation c'est mon objection et
philosophique c'est quand on vote on est
un représentant on est soi-même un élu
s'est on représente ceux qui ne peuvent
pas voter les générations passées les
générations futures et face à ce choix
on est dans une situation politique de
décision politique or qu'est-ce qu'une
situation de décision politique c'est
pas de choisir entre le bien et le mal
c'est de choisir entre le mal et le pire
est un voyou ce sont les principes
annoncés leurs ailes aux offres qui
parle à ce jour d'aujourd'hui l'idée
d'une communauté politique l'idée même
d'accepter la représentation c'est à
dire au fond de dire j'accepte celui qui
me représente par la légitimité de
l'élection même s'il n'est pas moi même
s'il ne défend pas mon intérêt celui
pour lequel j'aurai forcément votre
prochain
marche pas on ne vote pas mené
d'opérations hyper fragmenté très vite
on considère qu'on vote pour son intérêt
alors là il faut arrêter tout de suite
la démocratie il faut aller des
dictatures sont tout indiqués en
personne ne dira interrogé tous les ans
je vote pour mon intérêt on vote pour
ces enfants on vote pour son contexte
pour sa cité mais penser qu'on va dans
son intérêt c'est le contraire de la
démocratie penser d'ailleurs que l'élu
représente les intérêts de ceux qui ont
voté pour lui c'est aller à l'encontre
de la démocratie donc si on pense à ses
justes c'est pas la peine effectivement
en changeant tout vous pensez
qu'aujourd'hui les électeurs il pense
comme ça je pense que les électeurs sur
l'archipel isation où ils sont tous
focalisés sur alors d intérêt qu est
l'intérêt général ya plusieurs manières
d'interpréter dire que c'est pour ça
qu'il faut du débat il faut pas il faut
des votes etc moi je peux avoir une
conception de l'intérêt général qui peut
être différente de la vôtre et cette
confrontation effectivement doit être
arbitrée mais je vais jamais dire je
vote pour moi je vous mets au défi de
d'ailleurs discuté avec des gens qui
dirigent de vote uniquement pour moi
c'est pas l'égoïsme qui théoriquement
elle a animé la démocratie c'est le
principe majoritaire c'est la
représentation la délibération aussi au
parlement mais c'est aussi une forme de
culture une culture citoyenne culture
civique des valeurs
comment on fait pour entendre cette
demande là des citoyens d'être associé
davantage on parle de grand débat
permanent de consultation citoyenne est
ce qu'il faut creuser ça est ce que
c'est une manière de revitaliser notre
démocratie où là encore vous dites
attention je dis encore attention c'est
vraiment c'est vraiment le scoop
grincheux de la démocratie participative
je suis très à l'idée de démocratie
participative parce qu'elle est up
obscures ce concept n'est pas du tout
contrôler ses participations de qui et à
quoi et là dessus il ya beaucoup de
confusion en fait si on vend souvent
sous l'appellation de démocratie
participative une autre démocratie
représentative et on va créer un autre
conseil comme la convention citoyenne
sur le climat et on va créer ce faisant
ce sac est très intéressante et très
dangereux des chocs de représentation
plus personne ne sera qui représente
quoi j'ai un certain nombre de députés
de la république en marche discuter avec
eux me disais à la convention citoyenne
c'est le peuple non c'est pas le peuple
pops et vous là ce sont des citoyens qui
discute mais les représentants du peuple
ces sont les députés mélenchon a raison
ma personne et ça créé voilà c'est oui
c'est lui c'est la république c'est ce
sont les élus si les aigles est aussi
que les élus à l'assemblée sont élus
après la présidentielle dont tout
procède finalement avec avec le
quinquennat l'inversion du calendrier on
voit bien ici que voilà bien souvent la
question du vrai pouvoir se produit en
fait je suis d'accord avec vous mais
alors je ne vais pas être démagogique
terre que les élus travaillent beaucoup
les parlementaires travaillent beaucoup
et il faut les respecter dans leur
travail simplement je pense qu'ils ne
font pas le bon travail ils deviennent
des greffiers de l'exécutif a voté des
lois et il me semble que le vrai travail
d'un parlementaire c'est je rejoint les
thèses tout je trouve très convaincant
de françois cornut gentille qui dit il
faut élaborer réputé des républicains
qui dit il faut élaborer le diagnostic
est là le parlement ne passe pas
suffisamment de temps sur le diagnostic
sur la tentative d'élaborer un
diagnostic impartiale sur les questions
migratoires tout la question éducative
sur tous les problèmes parts a
aujourd'hui une personne personne ne
porte ça et ensuite d'évaluer les
politiques sans le contrôle de savoir si
la loi est nécessaire
le moment du vote est presque secondaire
ces techniques et puis la loi les lois
sont pas très bonnes elles sont bavardes
et son cd c'est pas cohérent enfin le
moment du diagnostic et le moment de
l'évaluation et la reddition pour
terminer avant d'accueillir à nos
chroniqueurs la la 6ème république
écrite par une constituante qui
permettrait d'asseoir une nouvelle
légitimité c'est pas une bonne idée non
plus vous voyez je suis là tri-nations
pas une bonne idée parce que je trouve
que notre vème république a fait la
preuve de son ca capacité de résistance
à des situations très très distinctes
les gilet jaune c'était un appel de
démocratie directe la crise de la
pandémie coville 19 c'était plutôt de la
verticalité lennon régime a été assez
région à l'égard de ces deux crises donc
je pense que voilà c'est pas mal comme
origine voilà merci beaucoup merci
beaucoup inter-états voyons comment
gouverner un peuple le roi c'est un
livre qui fait référence auquel je
renvoie nos téléspectateurs pour
continuer quelque part cette cette
conversation pour rester avec moi ouvrir
la page présidentielle de cette émission
pour terminer comme chaque soir on est à
16 jours du premier tour un fait
campagne au crible de nos chroniqueurs
et ça s'appelle le scan vous connaissez
désormais
mais avant mais dont il y a les deux pas
de fatalité au grand remplacement et de
la mole vous propose le rose dalmore
d'agir pour le climat l'assimilation
la république c'est moi la prendre
orange ma chronique
travail aux travailleurs le système aux
exclus il ya un vrai problème de pouvoir
d'achat rendre à la france sa grandeur
la russie a pas de mystère c'est de vol
et ils ont 2 ce soir nos chroniqueurs
dans le scanner manuel ducrocq bonsoir
bonsoir malien dans l'opinion
chroniqueuse régulière dans cette dans
cette émission vous allez vous parler
d'une nouveau délit que veut créer
sandrine rousseau de non-respect des
tâches domestiques j'ai hâte de vous
entendre et vous aviez que ça soit
impliqué avec vos propositions d'emblée
le carnet de campagne de stéphane
blakowski comme chaque soir l'oeil de
blake au hac est attiré par quoi
aujourd'hui avec depuis trois semaines
je vis l'oeil rivé sur les sondages il
se trouve que ce matin j'ai lu un
sondage qui nous dit que 80 % des
français sont extrêmement déçus par la
tournure que prend cette présidentielle
j'ai pas vu ce sondage vous flageller
pas myriam le bot compétence n'est pas
en cause parce que le sondage je les lui
ce matin certes mais il datait de deux
ans en fait de 2020 cbfm qui en 2020
avait posé la question français il leur
est demandé souhaitez vous que le second
tour et la prochaine présidentielle
oppose à nouveau maquereau et le pen
alors vous voulez voilà pouvoir la
réponse j'imagine oui voilà
80% des français ne voulaient surtout
pas d'un duel macron le pen tout mais
pas ça comme disait l affaire lui ce
trio on ne veut pas que ça recommence et
pourtant voilà à deux semaines du
premier tour on est parti tout droit
pour un second tour notable peine pour
vous jean luc mélenchon n'a aucune
chance de se qualifier
cette campagne il est tellement
prévisible que on donnerait tout pour un
rebondissement pour une surprise alors r
ma part belle au deuxième tour mais moi
je dis mais pourquoi pas de mélenchon
deviennent tour pourvu que ça soit pas
le duel macron le pen bon en même temps
l'or jean luc mélenchon lui même a l'air
d'y croire mais le trou de souris quoi
il croit moyen
j'aime pas trop les paris
donc moi je suis à réalise je pense que
j'ai une chance d'y être honnêtement
j'aurais pas dit ça il ya quelques mois
maintenant même si lui semble incertain
ça veut dire quoi fait on y va tout
droit macron le pen vous savez qu'on se
dirige vers le même de l'halloween que
qu'en 2017 c'est à dire la question
maintenant c'est de savoir si ce sera le
même résultat
du duel en 74 giscard gagne le match
avait 180 adhérents gagne nos matches
retour alors est-ce que marine le pen
pourrait prendre sa revanche chelsea et
battraient man et le maquereau le 24
avril il y en a qui croient et puis pas
forcément ce qu'on pense gérald darmanin
par exemple
elle est dangereuse pour le président de
la république elle peut gagner cette
élection présidentielle je sais que je
me dis mais non mais non mais non
peut-être parce que je suis habitué à
des électeurs qui ont tendance à voter
pour plein de raisons qu'on peut
d'ailleurs comprendre pour la droite
extrême qu'est la une stratégie qui a
l'air de fonctionner voilà que monsieur
zemmour l'a rendu plus molle si vous
permettez cette expression à l'époque on
avait beaucoup critiqué mais on constate
désormais tout le monde y va les doux
c'est plus sympa et puis travailleuses
bah non c'est une stratégie qu'il faut
dénoncer ça c'est pas une stratégie
aussi dédramatiser pour mobiliser son
électorat mais qu'est ce que vous voulez
dans la mesure où le candidat macro ne
se donne pas la peine de faire campagne
faut bien que d'autres s'y colle à sa
place je pense que vous avez lu la
presse c'était dans l'opinion mais les
échos sont aussi sur le sujet au qg de
macron tout le monde me off et ça va pas
du tout le candidat ne s'investit pas
dans la campagne ça va mal tourner donc
ce matin c'est elisabeth bornes bien
réputé effectivement pour être sacré
meneuse de meeting
se dévouer donc expliqué que pas du tout
le corps macron est très motivée elle la
première ça déborde d'enthousiasmé allez
voir je n'ai pas de doute qu'ils
souhaiteraient pouvoir
s'impliquer encore davantage dans la
dans la campagne en même temps on est
tous mobilisés vous l'avez dit moi je
serai à nîmes demain j'étais à
villeneuve saint georges hier je serai à
argelès ce soir donc on est tous
mobilisés bon je reconnais que question
charisme emmanuel macron un peu plus
bravo pour votre sens de l'euphémisme et
on peut même pas mieux faire leurs
proches à isabelle bond elle n'a jamais
fait de campagne électorale de sa vie
n'a jamais été candidat à une élection
donne pas elle qui va mener les
marcheurs à la victoire regardez ça
c'est un photo de deux meetings fin de
réunion rien à villeneuve-saint-georges
puisqu'elle disait que saab était en
meeting un petit faux thomas dragons
chez elle et toute la place occupée par
macron dont je ne sais pas la ram et il
n'était pas là donc je sais ne l'aimé
pas mon ego mon exemple mais je le
répète imaginez vous achetez du pâté de
lapin avec un patin avec un lapin par
des boîtes et oui je n'aimais pas la
première cagnotte
il ya procès là on dit à une affiche de
battre on voit macro et puis n'est pas
au meeting des déçus donc on plaisante
mais quand on habite de la conférence de
presse à maquereau vous êtes sûr d'être
élu je crois franchement ou pas loin
mais en même temps lionel jospin lui
aussi il était sûr mais sûrs d'être au
second tour en 2002 ça rejoint
exactement notre conversation de tout à
l'heure une campagne trop prévisible
sans enjeu est ce que ça peut avoir des
effets surprise sur le résultat final
oui enfin là on l'a eu comme plus grands
la plus grande plus jamais de mise mais
c'est vrai qu'on pourrait se dire enfin
on est focaliseront pourrait se
focaliser sur les idées voilà une chance
allait justement les idées on revient
avec vous et manuel vous allez revenir
sur la dernière sortie de sandrine
rousseau sur cet homme déconstruit alors
c'est pas vraiment l'homme déconstruit
ce que je voulais déconstruire et 20 ou
en tout cas décortiqué avec vous c'est
cette vidéo alors je sais pas comment ça
se passe chez vous les tâches ménagères
mais il ya quelqu'un qui a une idée très
précise très précise de la façon dont ça
devrait se passer et c'était le 21 mars
sur twitch un switch du média en ligne
mademoiselle regarder on en parle après
moi je voudrais qu'il y ait même une
possibilité de délit de non partage des
tâches domestiques parce que je pense
que privé est politique et que tant
qu'on ne rentre on ne donne pas les
moyens aux femmes de véritablement
obtenir l'égalité sur le partage et bien
on n'arrivera pas à faire reconnaître
dans un coup pas un bon partage
comme on fait reconnaître des violences
sexuelles au sein des couples et c'est
en fait le privé politique et ça c'est
vraiment un impensé des politiques
égalité femmes-hommes c'est que les
femmes font quand même huit heures de
plus de travail par semaine
domestique alors ça marchera comment
vous avez aidé alors reprenons donc
faire de un délit du nom partage des
tâches ménagères ça veut dire endroit
donc il ya un délit c'est qu'il faut
qu'il y ait une faute caractérisée donc
on en france par exemple on ne conduit
pas avec plus de 0,5 gramme d'alcool
dans le sang c'est une limite tangibles
on qu'il faudrait avant traîner les
hommes en justice pour des machines à
laver pas lancé
pas changé imaginez donc une échelle une
échelle de non réalisation des tâches
ménagères alors on le chiffre comment se
partage des tâches ménagères la sq on
part du principe que les huit heures par
semaine donnée par sandrine rousseau
font foi et hop tous les hommes
forcément les hommes d'ailleurs up to
sont des délinquants potentiels du
chiffon à poussière ont créé des
tableurs précis sinon pour chaque tâche
avec un chronomètre comment est ce qu'on
fait alors évidemment c'est complètement
grossier c'est même franchement
effrayant quand on se souvient de la
phrase suivante le privé est politique
c'est la même chose qu'est ce que ça
veut dire cette phrase ça veut dire
qu'au nom de l'égalité l'étape venir
chez vous et déterminer si votre vie
familiale est correct vous n'existez
plus en tant qu'individu vous êtes des
fonctions et on ne voit pas pourquoi ça
s'arrêterait aux tâches ménagères
d'ailleurs ce que vous mangez votre
sexualité vos amitiés pourquoi ne pas
tout réglementer et pourquoi ne pas tout
sanctionné pour moi c'est vraiment
effrayé l'éducation des enfants ni
l'éducation mais est-ce que c'est au
fond une forme de slogan pour faire
bouger les mentalités
est-ce qu' elle ne dit pas ça aussi pour
créer un électrochoc pour libérer les
femmes de ce poids des tâches ménagères
qui nous encombrent temps alors je ne
vois pas en quoi ça libérerait les
femmes de faire cette proposition là la
seule chose que dit cette proposition
c'est que la femme est une mineure à vie
elle a besoin d'un papa un papa l'état
vont à protéger parce que cette somme
n'est pas capable d'obtenir par
elle-même par le dialogue par
l'éducation l'amélioration sa propre vie
et l'homme est évidemment
intrinsèquement un russe un rustre qui
ne comprend que la violence symbolique
de l'état et pire quand on se moque de
cette proposition absurde d'envoyer des
juges avec un chronomètre pouvoir qui
valait on permet à toute une frange
conservatrice de se moquer de
l'intégralité d'un combat sur l'égalité
quand sandrine rousseau dit qu'elle veut
faire reconnaître ce délit comme on fait
reconnaître les violences sexuelles au
sein d'un couple je pense qu'elle se
trompe fondamentale et que c'est grave
la comparaison vaut choc oui c'est grave
parce que ça va arriver
oui en fait sa part c'est pas drôle du
tout ça veut dire que la violence
domestique est un sujet majeur est que
nombre de femmes ont du mal à faire
reconnaître devant la justice peut être
traité avec désinvolture qui va faire
cuire les nouilles ou qui va faire les
courses c'est banaliser un combat qui
est souvent une question de vie ou de
mort alors cendres et nous serons tous
nous rassure a dit abbas ce n'est que
moi mais c'est presque pire une femme
politique qui a brigué l'investiture de
son parti à la présidentielle
un prime dans l'opinion publique l'idée
que jaka y accoler un policier derrière
chaque bonhomme qui n'a pas envie de
vider le lave-vaisselle et hop c'est
gagné pas besoin d'éducation pas besoin
de sensibilisation des petits garçons on
sentira en sortir à la boîte pas
sanctions quand ils seront grands moi ça
c'est ce que j'appelle la politique de
la petite baignoire appliquée au débat
public la politique de la petite
baignoire selongey le bébé l'eau du bain
et on ne garde qu'une chose le canard de
bain en caoutchouc qui fait pouet pouet
amoled sur elle vous effraie cette
proposition la patrouille des tâches de
plus je pense qu'il faut pas prendre ça
du tout à la légère c'est une
proposition totalitaire le privé est
politique c'est une c'est le slogan
totalitaire par excellence est l'idée
que l'état a fonction à regarder tous
donc c'est pas du tout anecdotique c'est
en fait effectivement la version la plus
de la plus terrifiante d'une politique
totalitaire ce donc en fait par ailleurs
deuxième point une politique totalitaire
qui se combine avec la volonté de jury
10,6 et où c'est à dire de tout
contractualiser donc c'est un élément un
monstre
néolibérale et totalitaire c'est assez
particulier merci en tout cas monstrueux
merci merci à vous merci d'être venus et
henri tavoillot je rappelle le titre de
cet ouvrage comment gouverner un peuple
le roi c'était chez odile jacob merci
emmanuel pour cette chronique ce parti
pris et merci à vous stéphane très belle
soirée documentaire c'est le week end si
c'est leur profiter bien et la semaine
prochaine
[Musique]